THE DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
DR. FAUCI, THANKS AGAIN SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
FIRST OF ALL, WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION TO THE PRESIDENT SAYING
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS LIKE
FACEBOOK ARE, QUOTE, KILLING
PEOPLE WITH MISINFORMATION?
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
AND WHAT SHOULD BE DONE ABOUT
IT?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY
DISINFORMATION AND
MISINFORMATION IS REALLY, REALLY
A PROBLEM.
WHEN WE GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND ASK PEOPLE WHY
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET
VACCINATED, VERY OFTEN THEY COME
BACK WITH THINGS THAT ARE REALLY
JUST NOT TRUE.
SO, THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE SURGEON GENERAL, DR.
VIF EK MURPHY STRESSED THE
IMPORTANCE OF COUNTERING
MISINFORMATION WITH CORRECT
INFORMATION.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO, JIM, TO GET OUT
THERE WITH TRUSTED MESSENGERS,
TO GET PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
FACTS ABOUT VACCINE.
THE NUMBERS THAT YOU MENTIONED,
JIM, ARE STRIKING.
YOU CAN'T RUN AWAY FROM THOSE.
99.5% OF THE DEATHS THAT OCCUR
FROM COVID-19 ARE AMONG
UNVACCINATED INDIVIDUALS.
THAT'S A STRIKING STATISTIC.
>> AND YET PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT, THOUGH.
BUT DR. FAUCI --
>> WELL, IT'S THE TRUTH.
>> DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
MISINFORMATION, JIM.
PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE SOMETHING
THAT IS ABSOLUTE STATISTICAL
FACTS THAT ARE COLLECTED NOT
ONLY BY THE CDC BUT BY EVERY
ORGANIZATION THAT LOOKS AT THIS.
>> AND IT'S NOT JUST SOCIAL
MEDIA, THOUGH.
THE MOST-WATCHED TELEVISION SHOW
ON FOX NEWS RIGHT NOW IS
OUTRIGHT HOSTILE TO THE VACCINE.
AND IN THIS ENVIRONMENT, DO YOU
THINK WE COULD HAVE DEFEATED THE
MEASLES OR ERADICATED POLIO IF
YOU HAD FOX NEWS NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT WARNING PEOPLE ACT THESE
VACCINE ISSUES THAT ARE JUST
BUNK?
>> WELL, THAT IS A VERY GOOD
POINT, JIM.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE
EXTRAORDINARY, HISTORIC SUCCESS
IN ERADICATING SMALLPOX AND
ELIMINATING POLIO FROM MOST OF
THE WORLD, AND WE'RE ON THE
BRINK OF EERADICAING POLIO, IF
WE HAD THE PUSHBACK FOR VACCINES
THE WAY WE'RE SEEING ON CERTAIN
MEDIA, I DON'T THINK IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE AT ALL TO NOT
ONLY ERADICATE SMALLPOX.
WE PROBABLY WOULD STILL HAVE
SMALLPOX AND WE PROBABLY WOULD
STILL HAVE POLIO IN THIS COUNTRY
IF WE HAD THE KIND OF FALSE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEING SPREAD
NOW.
IF WE HAD THAT BACK DECADES AGO,
I WOULD BE CERTAIN THAT WE WOULD
STILL HAVE POLIO IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> AND THE DELTA VARIANT IS A
BIG FACTOR IN THIS SURGE, TOO.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING THE
ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER SAID IN
RECENT DAYS.
HE SAYS THEY'RE FINDING THAT THE
VACCINES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
EFFECTIVE AGAINST THE DELTA
VARIANT.
GOING AS FAR AS TO SAY VACCINES
ARE NOT ENOUGH TO BEAT BACK THE
VIRUS.
DOES THAT TRACK WITH THE DATA
THAT YOU'RE SEEING?
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, JIM, WE HAVE DO BE
CAREFUL TO REMEMBER WHEN THESE
VACCINES WERE SHOWN TO BE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE, THEY WERE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
SYMPTOMATIC, CLINICALLY APPARENT
DISEASE.
NOT NECESSARILY AGAINST
PREVENTING INFECTION, WHICH WE
CALL STERILIZING IMMUNITY.
THEY WERE QUITE EFFECTIVE IN
DOING THAT, BUT NOT NEARLY AS
MUCH AS THE 93, 94, 95% EFFICACY
IN PREVENTING SYMPTOMATIC
DISEASE.
SO, WHEN YOU START SEEING WHAT'S
CALLED BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS,
IF YOU LOOK CAREFULLY AT THEM,
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO EITHER HAVE
NO SYMPTOMS OR ONLY VERY MILD
SYMPTOMS.
SO, THE VACCINES ARE STILL VERY,
VERY EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
SEVERE DISEASE BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE RISK OF
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATHS,
WE'RE STILL WELL UP INTO THE MID
TO LOW 90s IN EFFICACY AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE, WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE NEED TO APPRECIATE THE
DIFFERENCE THERE.
>> RIGHT.
PEOPLE WERE MAKING THE MISTAKE
IN SAYING BECAUSE THERE ARE
BREAK THROUGHOUT CASES THERE
MUST BE SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE
VACCINES.
THE POINT IS TO PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM GETTING SERIOUSLY ILL AND
DYING.
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE GOING TO BE
INFECTIONS EVERY NOW AND THEN.
ONE AREA OF CONCERN FOR VACCINE
SKEPTICS HAS BEEN FULL APPROVAL
FOR A COVID VACCINE FROM THE
FDA.
YOU HEAR THAT FROM TALKING TO
PEOPLE AND I'M SURE YOU HEARD
THAT FROM TIME TO TIME TALKING
TO NEIGHBORS OR PEOPLE AT THE
STORE, THAT SORT OF THING.
WHEN CAN WE EXPECT FULL APPROVAL
FOR THE PFIZER VACCINE, FOR
EXAMPLE?
>> WELL, JIM, AGAIN, I DON'T
WANT TO GET AHEAD OF THE FDA,
BUT LIKELY FROM WHAT WE'RE
HEARING IT'S GOING TO BE IN A
MATTER OF A MONTH OR SO.
I WOULD HOPE BY THE TIME WE GET
TO THE END OF AUGUST THAT WE
HAVE FULL APPROVAL.
BUT YOU KNOW, EVEN BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN, PEOPLE SHOULD REALIZE
THAT THE DATA OF THE EFFICACY
AND REAL WORLD EFFECTIVENESS OF
THESE VACCINES IS REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY.
NOT ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES
BUT IN MULTIPLE COUNTRIES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
SO, I WOULD BE ASTOUNDED IF WE
DID NOT GET FULL APPROVAL WITHIN
THAT TIME FRAME.
>> AND A TIME LINE FOR VACCINES
FOR CHILDREN UNDER 12, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, WE'RE DOING THE STUDIES
NOW, JIM, OF WHAT IS CALLED AGE
DE-ESCALATION.
WE'RE LOOKING AT 12 TO 9 YEARS
OLD AND 9 TO 6, 6 TO 2 AND THEN
6 MONTHS TO 2 YEARS.
THUS FAR, THINGS LOOK GOOD, BUT
THE FINAL DECISION IS GOING TO
BE UP TO THE FDA.
AND I WOULD IMAGINE THAT LIKELY
WILL NOT HAPPEN UNTIL WE GET
WELL INTO THE WINTER TOWARDS THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
>> AND THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
FLORIDA IS HOME TO ONE OUT OF
EVERY FIVE NEW CASES IN THE U.S.
THAT IS REMARKABLE.
IT IS UNLIKELY, THOUGH, THAT THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR THERE, RON
DeSANTIS, WILL INSTITUTE MASKS
AND SOCIAL DISTANCING AGAIN.
HE'S VERY MUCH GOING IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION, AS YOU KNOW.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE OF THIS, DR. FAUCI,
IS PAC TIED TO GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
IS CURRENTLY SELLING MERCHANDISE
THAT SAYS DON'T FAUCI MY
FLORIDA.
I HATE TO RUIN A PERFECTLY FINE
SATURDAY AFTERNOON FOR YOU, DR.
FAUCI, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE
BEER COO SIS AND THAT SORT OF
THING THAT SAY DON'T FAUCI MY
FLORIDA?
>> YOU KNOW, JIM, IT ALMOST
DOESN'T DESERVE A COMMENT.
IT'S JUST -- YOU KNOW, TAKING AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO STANDS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH, FOR TRUTH, FOR DOING THE
RIGHT THINGS, TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY AND THE HEALTH OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH I HAVE DONE NOW FOR
FOUR DECADES AND TO USE MY NAME
IN A DEROGATORY WAY TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM DOING THINGS, THAT'S
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THEIR OWN
HEALTH, GO FIGURE THAT ONE OUT,
JIM.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT'S ALL
ABOUT.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT
ALL.
>> YEAH.
WHOEVER PLANNED THAT MAYBE HAD
TOO MANY BEERS.
BUT LET ME MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
QUESTION HERE.
GERMANY AND FRANCE ARE HAVING
SOME SUCCESS, AS YOU KNOW,
GETTING PEOPLE VACCINATED IN
RECENT DAYS.
THEY'RE GRANTING PRIVILEGES TO
PEOPLE WHO GET THE SHOT.
FRANCE JUST SAID YOU HAVE TO
SHOW PROOF OF VACCINATION OR A
NEGATIVE TEST TO GET INTO
RESTAURANTS.
THAT HAS LED TO A RECORD NUMBER
OF PEOPLE SIGNING UP FOR THE
VACCINE OVER THERE.
IS IT WORTH TRYING SOMETHING
ALONG THOSE LINES IN THE U.S.?
CREATE KIND OF AN EASY PASS OR
FAST LANE APPROACH FOR THE
VACCINATED AT RESTAURANTS AND
AIRPORTS AND THAT SORT OF THING?
CAN THAT TYPE OF APPROACH WORK
IN THE U.S.?
CAN WE GET THAT KIND OF A SYSTEM
IN PLACE TO MOVE SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE ALONG THAT ARE JUST
HESITANT TO GO GET VACCINATED?
>> YOU KNOW, JIM, I'M NOT GOING
TO PICK OUT ANY SPECIFIC
INCENTIVE AND ENDORSE IT OR NOT
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT IN GENERAL WE
REALLY WANT TO TRY EVERYTHING
WITHIN REASON.
WE'VE GOT TO GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
THESE ARE LIFE-SAVING
INTERVENTIONS.
AND IF WE COULD THINK OF SOME
CREATIVE WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED, ALL
THE BETTER.
I'M ALL FOR IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT COVID ORIGINS.
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR SOME TIME, FIELDING
QUESTIONS ON IT FOR A WHILE.
CNN HAS LEARNED THAT SOME SENIOR
BIDEN OFFICIALS THINK THAT THE
LAB LEAK THEORY, WHICH HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT FOR A WHILE NOW, IS
AS LEAST AS CREDIBLE AS THE
NATURAL ORIGINS EXPLANATION.
HAS YOUR THINKING ON THIS
CHANGED AT ALL?
DOES THAT --
>> NO.
>> ALIGN WITH YOUR THINKING ON
THIS?
>> I KEEP AN OPEN MIND AND SAY
THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER ALL
POSSIBILITIES UNTIL WE
DEFINITIVELY PROVE ONE, BUT I,
TOGETHER WITH MANY
HIGHLY-QUALIFIED VACCINOLOGISTS
AND VIROLOGISTS INCLUDING 21
EVOLUTIONARY BIOLOGISTS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD, INDICATE THAT
ALTHOUGH WE KEEP AN OPEN MIND
THAT IT IS POSSIBLE IT COULD BE,
AS THEY SAY, A LAB LEAK, THAT
THE MOST LIKELY EXPLANATION IS A
NATURAL EVOLUTION FROM AN ANIMAL
RESERVOIR TO A HUMAN.
ONCE YOU SAY THAT, WHICH I
BELIEVE IS THE MORE LIKELY,
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE YOU
EMPHASIZE THAT YOU STILL KEEP AN
OPEN MIND FOR ALL POSSIBILITIES,
INCLUDING A LAB LEAK.
>> AND SO YOU THINK NATURAL
ORIGIN OF THE VIRUS IS THE MORE
LIKELY, YOU STILL BELIEVE IT'S
THE MORE LIKELY SCENARIO.
>> I DO, YEAH.
RIGHT.
I'M NOT ALONE IN THAT.
A RECENT PAPER WAS PUT OUT BY 21
VERY WELL
INTERNATIONALLY-RESPECTED
VIROLOGIST AND EVOLUTIONARY
BIOLOGISTS WHO SAID THE SAME
THING AS I'M SAYING.
AND I RELY ON PEOPLE LIKE THAT
WHO HAVE GREAT EXPERIENCE IN
THIS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
WHO AGAIN ARE OPEN MINDED AND
SAYING IT IS CONCEIVABLE THAT
YOU MAY HAVE HAD A LAB LEAK.
SO YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP AN OPEN
MIND TO ALL POSSIBILITIES, BUT
THEY FEEL THAT THE MORE LIKELY
EXPLANATION IS A NATURAL
EVOLUTION FROM AN ANIMAL HOST TO
A HUMAN.
>> AND HAS THERE BEEN ANY
EVIDENCE TO MERGE THAT WOULD
POINT US IN THE DIRECTION OF A
LAB LEAK?
OR DOES IT REMAIN
HYPOTHETICAL-TYPE OF SCENARIO
HERE?
>> YOU KNOW, JIM, THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF ATTENTION PAID TO IT.
A LOT OF TWEETING, A LOT OF
EDITORIALIZING.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY CONCRETE
EVIDENCE THAT WOULD MAKE YOU
FEEL THAT ANYTHING OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS THAT'S NEW
MAKES YOU THINK IT'S MORE LIKELY
TO BE THAT.
AGAIN, HAVING SAID THAT, WE
STILL WANT TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND
THAT THAT IS A POSSIBILITY.
BUT I HAVE N